(soothing music)
- Careful dude, don't
fall off your skateboard.
(laughing)
- Oh shit, careful dude.
Careful, don't fall off that skateboard.
(laughing)
- Oh, fuck dude. So funny.
- So funny.
- Oh, fuck dude, my fucking
brother's on Skype dude,
my Ohio ass brother
and his like sexy wife.
- Dude when you just said Ohio,
it sounded like you were
saying an Asian word.
- What? That's so funny dude.
Ohio.
- Ohio.
(laughter)
- Fucking call him.
I wanna peep that sexy wife.
- Fuck yeah dude.
- Anderson.
- Craig, what the fuck is up dude?
- Hey how's it going man?
- Craig, Ohio.
- Fucking Ohio dude.
- Yeah, that's where I am.
- Dude he has no idea what
you're talking about dude.
So funny.
- Okay, honey, hang this up.
- Hon, I'm just,
- Hang it up.
- Oh fuck, it's Sheila.
Hey what's up Sheila?
- Hey Sheila.
- Sheila.
- What?
- Guys.
- Dude, I feel like a
crazy person right now.
Like no lie.
- What happened?
Totally legitimately,
I'm like in love with Sheila dude.
- Hit the button,
- I just did.
- [Sheila] I know, hit
the button next to it.
- That's the brightness.
- I cannot be with that woman, you know.
But, I think, that's like
a part of it, you know.
- What's your question, what do you want?
- Oh, sorry Sheila.
We had your ass muted there for a sec.
So, like, how are you?
- Oh, Sheila, don't be fucking mad.
- Sheila, come on sheila.
- Guys that's enough of that okay?
- Sorry dude, my bad.
So, Craig, how's your
life you little bitch?
- Well, it's pretty great.
You guys want to say hi to Lily?
- What the fuck is that?
- Yeah, Craig, what the fuck is that?
- Um, this is Lily, my daughter.
Your niece.
- You had a baby?
- Yeah Anderson, we sent
you an email with photos.
- Dude, I thought that
was a fucking joke dude.
- How old is that?
- [Craig] She's eight months.
- Oh dude (laugh)
do you know what that baby means?
- Sheila got fucked.
- Sheila got fucked!
(both laughing)
- Get her out of here Craig.
- Okay.
- Get her out of here right,
- Bye guys.
- Sheila!
- Oh, Sheila, come on.
- Garbage mouths.
You two need to get your act together.
Anderson, your girlfriend just died
and I don't think you're dealing with it.
(laughing)
- So funny dude.
She was like mid sentence.
Oh dude, so crazy dude.
Like I can't believe
Craig's a dad you know.
Like, I'm an uncle dude.
- Yeah dude.
Mazel Tov bro.
- It's so weird you know.
Like, I think if I'm being honest,
I'm like mad jealous of him, you know.
Like will I ever have that you know.
(laughs)
- Dude, dude.
You're a good dude, I see it.
I see it in everything you do.
- Thanks dude. I'm just like
always sad and I never know why.
You want to call them back and
show Sheila our scrotes?
- Fuck yeah dude.
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up.
I don't know if perhaps you were peeping
my fucking brothers sexy
ass wife in this episode,
but fucking I was.
- Hey, who else do you guys wanna see
in future episodes?
Let us know in the comment section.
Click those thumbnails
to see future episodes.
- Dude fucking share
your desires and ideas.
- Yeah, I could see like Jessica Alba
making an appearance.
- Fuck yeah dude.
Oh, dude, fucking Venus Williams dude.
- She's so lanky dude.
- Fuck yeah dude.
Paul Walker, who knows.
- Yeah...